Bill Amman is um you know a hedge fund
manager I think his net worth is four
billion he's married to the MIT former
MIT Professor MIT scholar um and and
very interesting sort of like design
scientist ner oxman bill akan was
basically as I'm I'm not totally sure
what his relationship with the Harvard
corporation which sort of oversees the
hiring and firing of cadine gay is but
it seems like I mean he's a massive
Harvard donor he got very out spoken
very riled up after the Congressional
testimonies very dissatisfied with Gay's
answers and seems to have you know
basically even before that been exerting
an awful lot of pressure on the Harvard
the Harvard Corporation and the
administrators of Harvard to basically
be treating um the sort of homas
sympathetic speech that was rif on
campus uh in a way that was I'm not
totally sure what he exactly wanted to
happen but it seemed like he felt
dissatisfied and angry and riled up with
the fact that students were um you know
acting as if the apartheid regime of
Israel is and I say that with air quotes
is responsible for the events of octo
October 7th um so bill akman was sort of
like very involved over the course of
October and November but it's still I
think at this point and then and then he
became very outspoken about wanting
specifically you know cing Gay's head on
a pike so to speak um but it sort of
clear what relationship exactly he had
behind the scenes with the powers that
be what do you think of that
eron yeah so again I I can't really I I
genuinely don't know you know what kind
of conversations may have gone on
between him and and the Harvard board
although although by by his own account
um and and everything I've seen reported
um I don't think that the Harvard board
was happy that he was going on this kind
of Twitter Crusade
and I actually suspect that it may have
he may have inadvertently prolonged
Gay's life as president of Harvard
University um because they think they
felt they felt like if they got rid of
her you know at height of amman's
anti-gay tweet storms it tws sorry yeah
anti- claing gay to be clear uh anti
ciding get yes I I'm sure bill akman um
loves people of all SE orientations
anyway um
um I I think that they probably felt
like if they if they oued her when he
you know at the moment when he was
demanding they do it it would look
really horrible if they were
capitulating to to outside pressure and
donors um and he himself tweeted that he
heard that that was one of the reasons
why they initially on December 12th I
believe affirmed their support for gay
um and did not fire her
you know in terms of the the role he
played throughout the rest of the
controversy he certainly Amplified the
plagiarism allegations on Twitter um
more people saw
them so maybe that played a role but to
be honest I think that they would have
gone pretty viral even without him and I
think it sounds like it sounds as if
what really happened was that once these
plagiarism allegations hit a critical
mass
support for her really cratered among
the faculty and students too and it just
became untenable for her to lead the
university and I really don't think
Amman had very much to do with that I
not to Pat myself on the back but I
think it was largely the strength of
just the allegations out of out of my
reporting on them that made it hard for
people to uh ignore um just the SPs uh
spoke for themselves and yeah yeah and
if anything again yeah I think that I
think that probably the collapse and
support would have happened even more
quickly had Amman not been tweeting so
aggressively because I think that those
aggressive
tweets uh made faculty feel dug in and
like they had to defend gay against this
outside pressure but once the facts
really changed and became so
sufficiently unflattering they kind of
said uh even if we're even if in some
ways we're giving into you know come on
can this person really be the president
of Harvard with the sunny strikes
against her so the day after gay was
fired AKA resigned um you know depending
on sort of which narrative you want to
go with she technically resigned but I
think it's pretty clear that it's one of
those you need to you know pack up your
things and get out of here type
conversations but after that Amman
started tweeting about Dei um this is a
little bit kind of out of left field I
mean this ties into a lot of the long
critiques uh that many of us have lodged
against some of these Elite institutions
but the thing that's kind of interesting
is that I think Amman somewhat
single-handedly turn this into a Dei
conversation maybe Chris rufo was
somewhat involved in that as well uh
what exactly how did that pivot happen
can we read can we just read a little
bit of his uh very long Twitter post
please don't read the whole thing he
says you know in in light of today's
news I thought to's news being Claud
Gay's resignation I thought I would try
to take a step back and provide
perspective on what this is really all
about uh and scrolling down past a lot
of this uh I ultimately concluded that
anti-Semitism was not the core of the
problem it was simply a troubling
warning sign it was the quote Canary and
the coal mine I came to learn that the
root cause of anti-Semitism at Harvard
was an ideology that has been
promulgated on campus an oppressor
oppressed framework that provided the
intellectual bull workk behind the
protests then I did more research the
more I learned the more concerned I
became and the more ignorant I realized
I had been about
Dei yeah this whole thing kind of
annoyed me because a Dei like we can
talk about the oppressor oppressed sort
of social justice framework but Dei is
almost sort of the more recent
incarnation of that right like Dei sort
of more frequently applies to admissions
practices and hiring practices um it's
okay I guess if we want to expand that
term to sort of be the Umbrella by which
we talk about these other ideologies
that have been rampant on campus but
it's a little bit weird and then the
other thing that annoys me about this is
it's just like were you born yesterday
Bill Amman right like this has been
going on for I mean I entered College in
2014 and I left in 2016 I think in 2013
2014 that was sort of the beginning of
this most recent round of Campus speech
craziness and absurd double standards
but I'm a little bit like well Bill
Amman you've been donating to Harvard
for an awful long time and you sort of
weren't like who was minding the store
who was keeping watch clearly not you
what do you think
Aaron yeah I had I had largely the same
reaction uh especially not not so much
to Amman but to
um Mark Rowan and some of these other
donors uh who fomented the revolt
against pen I was like oh now you
realize that they're all terrorists and
they're crazy okay great well we've been
telling you that for decades and now you
figure it out all right like uh little
belated um I will say in amman's
particular defense that he has gone
beyond just saying wait anti-Semitism is
a problem on campus and some of the
activists are a little crazy to seeming
to really Embrace a pretty thoroughgoing
critique of the entire Dei regime and
yes Dei is a recent incarnation of it
but I I think when you look at his posts
he seems to understand oh wait there's
kind of systemic race discrimination at
at universities um and basically anyone
who
uh you know anyone who's not a straight
white male can claim victim status and
use that status to uh to gain special
privileges and suppress any kind of
speech that they deem offensive or
harmful huh that seems bad you know he's
actually he seems to understand now the
nature of the problem um and I think
that's a good thing um and he seems to
have understood it better than some
other yeah yeah well I want to ask you
about the nature of the problem that
he's outlining there which what what
he's saying and this is something I've
heard this is an argument I've heard a
lot lately that
the uh anti-Semitism that has been
expressed in these anti-israel or Pro
Palestine movements is a natural
outgrowth of Dei this is where Dei leads
to
anti-Semitism um is there anything to
that in your estimation is that a sound
argument yeah I think it's a very sound
argument I mean let me try to try to put
it in the clearest way possible think
about okay think about what a lot of Dei
rhetoric focuses on it focuses on
disparities between groups and the
premise is always that any disparities
are caused by oppression um of some sort
uh you know any any kind of innocuous
explanation for the dispari certainly
any explanation that just says well you
know one group just happens to like be
you know better at rising to the top of
this field that's certainly not allowed
right
um well look that creates a bit of a
problem because in case you haven't
noticed Jews are overrepresented in a
lot of fields um they're overrepresented
they are over represented in finance
they are in fact over represented in
Hollywood and although they're less over
represented on Ivy League campuses than
they used to be for various reasons we
can maybe get into they are still over
represented on Ivy League campuses so
represented on sports teams correct
they're not um and yet no one and yet no
one thinks that that is a reflection of
systemic anti-jewish Prejudice on the
part of the NBA uh so for some reason no
one's made that argument but uh but look
uh if if you think that all disparities
especially disparities that that that
favor white coded individuals like Jews
are ipsofacto illegitimate and and
racist well
uh then it looks like that then we have
a problem because Jews are in fact over
represented in a lot of fields and and
uh by the logic of Dei that should
suggest that they have kind of unearned
privilege at that's the
most innocuous formulation and the least
innocuous formulation is they they have
their privileges as a result of a kind
of illegitimate almost conspiracy or or
or system of power that that keeps
others down um and it's not hard to see
how that's going to just turn into sort
of old fashion Jews control everything
they're evil anti-Semitism um that
really is the is the causal pathway from
Dei to anti-Semitism now now there's
another dimension here too which I think
is related but separate which is just
that in practice this Dei proponents
wouldn't say this out loud but I think
this is this is implicit in a lot of the
rhetoric there's just kind of a
knee-jerk assumption ooh kind of white
people have unearned privilege and tend
to be the bad guys um and white people
can't be victims and most Jews in
America are white now some Jews would
say oh I'm not really white blah blah
blah but in practice most of them are
classified as white by the census they
look white and in the social
construction of race that is currently
operative in the United States Jews are
white um so but when you've said that
all white people are part of of this you
know system of power that that that
makes them
oppressors then the very idea that Jews
who are a subset of whites could be
victims just becomes much more harder to
to cognize um and I think that's the
other big part of the story right this
is this is as much a lot of the
anti-Semitism I think here is is made
it's not necessarily caused by but it's
it's made possible by a kind of anti
this phrase might get me in trouble but
a kind of anti-white cultural default
where whites are just assumed to be in
power and kind of bad in some
way right when that is the cultural
default at these institutions it becomes
harder to talk about subsets of white
people who may be victimized in various
ways or at least for whom that
Assumption of power uh and privilege may
be a little more
um so I do think de and kind of broader
Notions of progressive
identitarianism do have a lot to do with
anti-Semitism um I would I would just
say that you know having having made
that argument you know it is important
to distinguish between harsh criticism
of Israel and anti-Semitism right those
are not necessarily the same thing and
just because progressivism makes people
focus more on the settlements or
whatever like that's not intrinsically
anti-Semitic hey thanks for watching
that clip from our new show just asking
questions you can watch another clip
here or the full episode here new
episodes drop every week so subscribe to
reent TV's YouTube channel to get
notified when that happens or to the
just asking questions podcast on Apple
Spotify or any other podcaster